england heading to the knockouts for
euro 2020
uh we want to know i know you're asking
at home this morning what does the
former england player john barnes think
about it well luckily enough we've got
him with us now hello to you john
morning jay how are you i am great thank
you i love that painting behind you talk
to me
about um the football uh how do you
think england is doing so far we are
through
but it's not been scintillating has it
well the main thing is that we're
through and we haven't conceded a goal
because of course in england
we love to um over emphasize how
fantastic we are when we play well and
then when we
don't play so well we see how terrible
we are we're a very good side um we had
a good
first game against croatia not so good
second game against
um scotland and of course would be czech
republic last night
good first half average second half but
the thing is we're through we haven't
conceded a goal
we're not scoring many goals but let's
see what happens in the um in the
knockout phases
as to who we get yeah both girls um
scored by sterling of course is he your
player
so far of the tournament is concerned
he's not my player at the tournament
he's my player of england because we're
gonna have only scored two goals i mean
there are other
there are other teams italy have scored
seven or eight goals
germany looks strong so i don't think
any of the england players so far the
players of the tournament
but he's been obviously our our shining
light but we're waiting for harry kane
to
to catch fire because we're going to
need him the further we go in the
competition yeah because look who we
might be facing next talk to us about
that
well that's the thing with the uh the
new format of three teams going through
it could be any one
um of of of germany france
or portugal um which would be any one of
them would be difficult but we're hoping
for hungary to bring a surprise and and
if they can beat germany it could be
hungry that's what we want
so um we've got a difficult one if it's
one of those three
but as gary southgate says if you want
to win the tournament you have to play
everyone and of course while it would be
better to play them in the final later
on you know we we
have to play whoever is put in front of
us who do we not want in the next game
out of those
three i would want france i think france
are my favorites um as much as you
wouldn't really want to play germany
necessarily or portugal but out of those
three
i think france on the team i wouldn't
want to play okay um
gary southgate yesterday was talking
about the absence of ben chilwell and
mason mount of course they had to
quarantine after coming into contact
with a player from scotland who was
covered positive
he described it as a bizarre situation
and full of contradictions
what are your thoughts well
um it was strange um not so much okay
them
isolating because before the game they
shook his hand and gave him a bit of a
a hug a little bit of a hug but for the
scottish players not having to isolate
the strange because of course they would
have been addressing with him
they would have celebrated after the
great results against england i'm sure
they would have hugged
um so not so much that they had to
isolate as much as
as much as they shook his hand and gave
him a bit of a couple in my opinion
i'm not a scientist i don't know how the
virus spreads necessarily
that seemed a bit strange but for them
to have to isolate and the scottish did
not
that seemed a bit strange okay and what
about um having
75 capacity or um crowd
at wembley do you have a view on that
well of course the view i have is that
fantastic from a plane point of view
that you want a crowd there
as to the safety aspect of things i'm
not once again i don't know
um others i'm not a scientist but i do
know the the issue whereby certain
people are saying how time we go to
restaurants but they can go to football
or have someone not go to the theater
but if you go to football you can't
please everybody um but i would like to
trust them enough
for them to as we've seen in um one of
the countries i think it was
hungary where it's a full stadium um
there are there are countries whereby
they are allowing certain amounts of
people to go back so as to whether it
should be
three-quarters full or five thousand or
ten thousand or twenty thousand
i i don't know but it's good to see that
that people are getting back into
football stadiums okay
and your prediction for the cup are you
saying france or do you think england
can do it
well i'm saying france um
i'm but i'm hoping for england not to
play the middle next round then maybe we
could have a france england final
uh let's see who england are playing
then if i come back on and
and it's france then he can ask me then
i will that's exactly what i'll do
that's somebody else we've booked for
wednesday we're sorting out our guests
already for next week thanks very much
indeed thanks a lot